[Music]
could you please speak to
having
enough you've you've spoken about or at
least written about how your hedge fund
could have taken over your life
and you could have just ended up as a
capital accumulator as uh as your
full-time
full-time job plus
how did you make the decision to wind it
down and how do you think about having
enough because that that's not it
doesn't strike me as
something i come across
often with people who are really good at
investing
the way i got into the investment world
i was an academic and i was curious and
i found things interesting and i wasn't
really in there to get rich i was in
there
to deal with interesting math problems
that kept coming up
blackjack roulette was a math physics
problem investing was
for me lots and lots of math so
i i enjoyed that
so i just i just do things i like
and
i don't worry about money as my
former sister-in-law once said
do what you love and the money will
follow she wrote a book with that title
and
i said you know that's that's right
do what you love and the money may
follow and if it does that's fine if it
doesn't you're still doing what you love
and what's important in life i think
is the journey
and the people
you know and you spend your time with
and
how how you spend your time otherwise
also so
that's how i looked at things and i
started out as a child of the great
depression so i knew what it was like to
have
basically no money
i used to sleep
four or five hours a night in high
school and get up at two or three in the
morning in developer newspapers
and i made 25 dollars a month which
seemed like really big money
and i
saved part of that for college and
invested part of it in
science equipment
chemistry telescopes electronics and so
forth too just because i like
playing with those things and learning
about them
so
my goal wasn't to make money it was to
have
a good life and enjoy myself and have
fun and it just so happened that it
turned out a lot of money too
so
what i found though in the investment
world is lots of people go in it for the
money and when they do
they keep going and going and going and
it's a validation of them
and that they can't stop
they end up with
oh five or ten
villas
a yacht
a jet and
even if you let's imagine you have uh
five houses just to take an example
how much of your time you're gonna spend
in each house you can't be on average
more than a fifth [ __ ] by math and
you're not going to be in your house all
the time anyhow you can be vacationing
traveling meeting and so on so maybe
it's a sixth or seventh of the time on
average
now some houses are going to you're
going to spend more time in it somewhere
so you may spend a 10th or 15th of your
time
or none of the time don't have your time
almost in one of those houses so you end
up with a whole lot of stuff to manage
and take care of and
you end up hiring people to do that
so you don't have to do it and then you
have to manage those people
and then you have to hire people to
manage the people who manage the people
and so on it's like running a business
it's terrible
you don't get to enjoy the important
part of your life which is time
did you
have a set point at which point you knew
you're going to exit the business so to
speak or was there a particular day
that prompted a particular experience
that prompted you to say enough is
enough
i want out do you remember what the
catalyst was if there was one
i
wasn't having fun anymore it was turning
into work
and i said well i don't need to do this
i have enough wealth i'm never gonna
spend it all
why
keep doing this
so i decided to wind it down
it was fun for a long time because there
were challenging problems and i
it was
challenging to
try to figure out new things and to deal
with all the issues that came up but
when it became
bureaucratic and paperwork and
a grind where i had to do things i
didn't want to do that was enough it was
time time to go
and
it was the same thing in academia i
loved academia but there were aspects to
it that became burdensome
committee meetings
endless reviews
grant proposals
what i liked was research
and teaching
and the people that i met there the
students and the faculty that were
smart and challenging
and if it was only that
i'd still be there but it wasn't only
that
and i found other things that were
equally or more fulfilling
so anyhow i just migrate to where where
i want to be
i don't have a set
thing that i have to keep doing
you